we are recreating blockbuster movie
posters with Asians Maggie and I are
going to be recreating the cover of mr.
and mrs. Smith
there are many movie posters with Asians
on them and even if they are usually
there company by other people you know I
just really wanted to see Asians being
represented as the people that I know in
real life who are a badass be like super
smart show that by recreating movie
posters where we are the heroes for once
instead of the sidekick I've never been
described as sexy never described as
swab before people call me cute friendly
and funny but like never sexy the male
lead in the romantic interest Angelina
Jolie embodies this perfect human being
she's sexy she's smart she kicks butt
Brad Pitt like to think that I could
even like share the same space with him
was I'm sure to be growing up but I'm
gonna do it now and I'm gonna kill it
Brangelina we're coming for you
so today I'm doing the movie poster for
Jurassic world you know growing up you
sort of look at the meat and you can
relate to other people who don't
necessarily look like you but to wake up
every morning and look in the mirror and
just know you look one way and the look
of the world around you and realize I
don't look like anyone else that that
can be very isolating it would have been
nice for me to sort of know that ok I'm
not alone I do have more aspirations I
can look outward and I can see that
there are so many different things that
I could do or could done live just
allowed me to dream larger and there's a
lot of perceptions tied to what it means
to be an Asian that are not seen as
desirable as leading person material
where we have Asian Americans who are
not necessarily being ridden based on
assumptions about what an Asian is or is
not we just need rules that are human
and are written to be human today I'm
going to be Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows part-2 movie poster when I was
told I would do that I was like oh do
you want me to be Ronald Weasley and I
was told no you're gonna be the lead
seeing three Asian like leaves in a film
is so cool I am a huge Harry Potter fan
there are two Indian characters that I
remember in Harry Potter I mean I loved
reading about them in the books that I
loved that they existed
I obviously related to other characters
in the book as well but they definitely
stick out to me as to that I really
remember growing up there was never kind
of that role-model feeling in Hollywood
because we look up to everybody that we
see in the media the only Asians I saw
growing up was Jackie Chan and Jet Li
even now there aren't any blockbuster
movies starring Asian lead it changes
the perception of a certain community to
the rest of the world too
it's not like oh I only like them
because they look like me but it does
kind of make you feel like oh like maybe
I could do that
today I'm doing the Mockingjay poster
which I'm a little bit nervous about
like thinking about how a Singaporean
Chinese American immigrant like me could
one day be some sort of Katniss Everdeen
figure was impossible it's not just
about putting people of color in
situations where they aren't normally
it's about bringing a diversity of
perspective of culture of background to
every role in Hollywood the culture that
you grow up in it informs every decision
that you make and as creative people it
informs all of our creative decisions as
well as for mainstream American media
the lack of Asian identity is not just
missing out on a whole perspective and
culture of people who are willing to add
to the conversation it's doing a real
injustice to younger audiences who feel
like that's something that they can
never attain when simply that's just not
true whatever they see on their screen
they can accomplish they are interesting
enough they are talented enough all we
have to do is keep trying
really it isn't that we necessarily need
more of one things that we need more
roles that are written in a multi-layer
of the 10 dimensional way I think I'm as
sexy as Angelina Jolie and I believe it
it's super important for us to encourage
future generations you're capable of
doing great things you're capable of
doing this or that and you're worth it
we might not be the Katniss Everdeen
today but it's going to happen
good you're done yes all right I'll see
you tomorrow